this liquid marble
is made of extremely salty water
so salty that crystals form as soon as
the water begins evaporating
turning salty water into salt crystals
is a neat trick
but also a tricky problem salt and other
mineral deposits
plague power plants which turn heat into
electricity
and require loads of water to cool their
systems
a typical power plant uses about a
billion gallons of fresh water
each year even highly purified water
contains traces of salt
and the pesky deposits left behind put a
100 billion dollar hit
on the gdps of industrialized nations
to fix this problem it's best to focus
on the surfaces the drops are cooling
rather than the droplets themselves new
research shows the texture of a material
surface
at super small scales the micro and
nanometer level
changes the shape of salt crystals that
form as water evaporates
surfaces with micro sized wells allow
the water
to flatten and spread out which ends up
clogging the surface
with crystals but nano size gaps force
the crystals to grow
upward creating deposits that resemble
elephants
and jellyfish these crystal critters
stand out
and are easier to remove they can even
drift away on their own
researchers made the crystals walk and
roll by
fiddling with the timing of heat applied
to the water
it's more than entertainment by tweaking
the interplay between
surface textures temperatures and
crystal sizes
engineers could design power plants to
prevent the buildup of minerals
and possibly even cool them with salt
water instead of fresh water
if nothing else it's worth a closer look